in honor of the upcoming 100th
anniversary of the national football
league the pro football hall of fame has
a centennial class of 2020. there's a
separate procedure that circumvents the
normal voting process i've got issues
with that although we don't have enough
time for me to go all the way down that
rabbit hole here the bottom line is a
separate blue ribbon panel has been
established for the purposes of
eventually naming a block of 15 who will
get in without a normal vote big cat and
there are some names on there who i
think deserve to get in this whole thing
is supposed to be about
cleaning up past messes getting people
who have been traditionally overlooked
who have been forgotten who are in the
dust bin of nfl history and deserve to
be in the hall of fame that's why i'm
troubled by the presence of names like
bill cower there's never been talk about
bill cower being in the hall of fame and
he's coached within the last 12 years if
this is more for guys like don coryell
and tom flores guys who have been
overlooked they should be the ones who
ultimately get in that 15-member list
okay so i'll give it to you right now
tom floors jimmy johnson from the
coaches and steve sable needs to be in i
can't believe he's not that's crazy
that's steve sanders if you are of a
certain age your introduction to the nfl
was were those films
and ed sable his dad the founder of nfl
films is already in but steve is the guy
who was more recognized he was more
front and center and ultimately took
over the company and made it what it is
paul tagliabue is the most controversial
name on that list though cause he's
already been put on the t he was a
finalist in the contributor category a
couple of years ago and the voters said
no he has a chance of being in this
15-member group where the voters never
have a chance to say yes or no i think
this is a way to get him in and he will
get in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports